bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
dans le kiosque votre magazine culturel
regardons ensemble sommaire de cette
émission la période des vacances d'hiver
est l'occasion de sortir en famille et
pourquoi pas à la ferme la bergerie
nationale à rambouillet is les couleurs
du cirque pourquoi ce thème toutes les
explications avec notre invité dans
quelques instants à l'occasion de la
célébration des 30 ans du hip hop sur le
territoire le musée de la ville de saint
quentin en yvelines présente une
nouvelle exposition jusqu'au 28 juin
nicolas gervais a rencontré mélanie lévy
thiébaut chef d'orchestre elle nous
parlera du concert de l'orchestré
manifesto qu'elle dirigera le 15 mars à
la merise
la période des vacances scolaires est
l'occasion d'occuper les enfants par des
activités instructive et ludique et
pourquoi pas une visite à la ferme la
bergerie nationale à rambouillet propose
tous les après midi de nombreuses
animations pour soir fabrique bien lieu
ce soir alors vous êtes responsable de
l'animation à la sphère donc de la
bergerie nationale à rambouillet donc
cette année enfin chaque année
d'ailleurs vous organiser pour les
vacances différentes animations pour les
familles et cette année vous avez choisi
le thème du cirque les arts du cirque
alors pourquoi le cirque à la ferme
effectivement pour chaque vacances on a
décliné un thème et donc il nous restait
le mois de les vacances de février où on
avait des commencé à réfléchir sur une
animation plus autour du carnaval mais
c'était difficile de se renouveler et en
constatant finalement l'enrôlement des
enfants sur de l'acrobatie sur des
bottes de paille ou sur l'initiation à
l'apprentissage à la transformation des
produits laitiers ou des oeufs on s'est
dit que finalement c'était des choses
qu'on pouvait appliquer dans le cadre
dans le cadre du cirque donc finalement
ce qui est important pour nous pour
l'équipe des animateurs ces deux
effectivement c'est le cirque mais c'est
un cirque adapté au monde agricole voilà
c'est pas on va pas faire finalement des
animations qui n'ont aucun sens avec le
projet d'établissement de la bergerie
qui est donc une culture la bergerie
c'est une exploitation agricole un lieu
de production
qu'elle est du coup votre philosophie
éducatif donc effectivement ce que nous
proposons aux visiteurs c'est ce qui est
finalement proposé dans le cadre de
l'établissement de la bergerie nationale
c'est sur la thématique de produire et
de consommer autrement effectivement
moi je suis responsable de l'équipe des
animateurs à côté de ça il ya aussi une
équipe de techniciens qui voit là va
essayer de produire de vraiment
différemment par rapport à des
thématiques autour de l'agriculture
biologique autour de delà du bien-être
animal donc le rôle des animateurs c'est
finalement de vulgariser d'expliquer ce
que les techniciens font de façon
quotidienne et de l'expliquer à des
enfants donc après il ya différentes
possibilités donc les vacances on ne
peut pas faire autrement que de le faire
de façon ludique puisque c'est vraiment
la demande des citadins et des visiteurs
c'est de venir s'amuser donc on s'amuse
tout en apprenant effectivement que sur
cette exploitation agricole
on respecte l'animal ont produit les
aliments sur place on essaye de
valoriser le plus proche possible les
produits donc dans le cadre des circuits
courts et la boutique gourmande voilà ça
c'est vraiment produire pour la cij doit
résumer c'est produire et consommer
autrement
exactement alors donc pendant les
vacances a jusqu'au 2 mars
donc effectivement pour ses vacances il
ya plusieurs plusieurs possibilités pour
les enfants on a un spectacle animalier
où finalement les enfants vont se
retrouver dans la situation du berger de
son chien puisqu'on va guider les
animaux
voilà un peu en situation effectivement
chose qu'on peut voir
assez souvent quand on fait ce qu'on
appelle nous des démonstrations de
chiens de berger donc là finalement
c'est les enfants qui sont deux qui sont
acteurs on a des tours de magie et donc
ce sont des tours de magie pour
expliquer la transformation du lait en
beurre et d'expliquer aussi là
il faut venir dans mais c'est très
simple après voilà ces dépôts il ya
toute une mise en scène mais finalement
c'est tout ce qu'on explique aux enfants
c'est que c'est des choses qui peuvent
reproduire à la maison donc pour faire
du beurre c'est simple il faut
simplement avoir de la crème et de la
baratte et donc c'est simplement la
secouer et ont fait aussi le même genre
d'animation on va dire de de magie
autour de l'oeuvre pour expliquer les
composants de l'oeuf donc voilà on
arrivait lancé tous des produits de
processus d'affaires voilà on a un
espace maquillage où les enfants ont
vont confectionner un masque avec de la
peinture à base de ce qu'on appelle la
tempura c'est une peinture ancestrales
et après différents ateliers de
jonglerie ou d' équilibre avec aussi des
produits de la ferme sur des bottes de
paille on a fabriqué des boules des
balles de jonglage avec du blé on essaye
de en tout cas de valoriser au maximum
ce qu'on est capable de produire sur
place écoutez moi je vous propose c'est
qu'on regarde justement une après midi
passée à la ferme à la bergerie pour
avoir justement une étendue de
différentes animations
pendant les vacances d'hiver place au
cirque à la ferme la bergerie nationale
à rambouillet propose tous les
après-midis différentes animations
autour des arts du cirque des parcours
d'acrobaties entre les bottes de paille
la fabrication de masques à partir de
peintures au jaune d'oeuf ou encore des
tours de magie où l'on transforme la
crème amber au programme également des
numéros de dressage à deux tigres ni de
lyon ahmed ewa n'oseront l'avantagent
d'être élevé depuis tout jeune parmi les
chiens de berger puisque ce sont des
oies qu'on utilise pour entraîner les
fio et donc elles ont l'habitude de se
faire un petit peu malmené par les
chiens et donc les enfants on va dire
que c'est un petit peu les vacances pour
elle et du coup il ya aucun n'y a aucun
souci à ce niveau-là
il faisait une ronde et on devait mettre
les woods dans la ronde et on se fait
baisser et si quelqu'un de bouvier et ba
et ba loi elle prend sa place et après
elle s'enfuit d'enlever nos bras et les
yeux devaient passer en dessous mais y
en a quelques-unes qui s'est échappé en
fin d'après midi la visite 100 % nature
se termine par la découverte des soins
aux animaux moutons chèvres poules et
vaches voilà de quoi émerveiller nos
petits apprentis fermiers
affreux dirais qu'on a vu dans leurs
reportages donc des oies c'est pas très
sympa les annonces a pas très bonne
réputation serait c'est vrai ça peut
passer mais celles ci sont tellement
l'habitude des enfants qu'elles sont
c'est ce que disait votre est mieux
structuré cas limites avec les enfants
c'était des vacances vous allez au final
tout mon voyage elle reste un peu
effrayé mais bon elle ne passe pas
d'accord parce que moi j'ai souvenir un
petit du nord qui m'a poursuivie quand
même
bon bon j'aime gurb alors comme on a pu
le voir les visiteurs sont donc
majoritairement des familles qu'est ce
qui est important pour vous justement
dans ce lien qui est créé avec la
famille mais parce que effectivement
donc beaucoup de beaucoup de grands
parents avec leurs petits enfants ou des
parents avec des avec des jeunes enfants
ont finalement c'est c'est un public
d'enfants entre 3 on va dire entre trois
et dix ans après après on pourra
peut-être un jour proposer autre chose
mais en tout cas c'est surtout ce genre
de public on accueille effectivement
pour nous c'est important déjà de
travailler de façon locale avec les
enfants on va dire du territoire parce
que c'est pour nous quelque chose de
prioritaire de finalement d'expliquer
tout la finalité
de la production animale de la finalité
de l'établissement et de pouvoir aussi
après permettre de
rencontres avec les techniciens ou avec
le commerçant qui va vendre ses produits
parce qu'on a une boutique gourmande se
replacer effectivement
cours exactement une fois on est sur le
véhiculer le message du produire et
consommer à travers exactement pour les
futurs consommateurs ces futurs
consommateurs effectivement et
moi je trouve que ce qui est vraiment
primordial c'est dit j'espère cette
créer des vocations quand ces enfants là
moi j'ai des jeunes enfants qui m'attend
sont devenus des adultes ça fait
quelques années que j'y suis ben voila
j'ai des ados qui sont maintenant deux
des animateurs donc ça fait ça fait
plaisir de voir qu'on a réussi à créer
des vocations alors dans les nouveautés
aussi vous allez mettre en place la très
prochainement un nouveau circuit visite
oui
c'est un peu dans les tuyaux depuis
quelques quelques temps on a enfin pu
commencer à le matérialiser par une
exposition sur la mare la maréchalerie
ce que nous on a bat baptiste on l'a
prénommé c'est un sentier
d'interprétation où finalement le
visiteur pourra appréhender le monde
agricole de façon interactive avec
différents espaces adaptés à différents
à différents niveaux donc d espace
sensoriel pour les enfants des espaces
peut-être plus technique avec des
expositions plus tôt pour les adultes
voire voir des ados on a aussi mis en
place depuis quelques temps une
application avec le smartphone et les
flashcodes qui permet aussi à des à des
ados des adultes de s'amuser aussi ça
devient complètement intergénérations
c'est prévu pourquoi pas prêt je
crois que ça
c'est un travail de plusieurs années
donc on va dire que dans un ou deux ans
on aura bien commencé dans cinq ans
peut-être ça sera terminé alors juste
pour conclure parce qu'on a eu beaucoup
de temps pour la petite histoire raconte
et non l'origine la naissance de la
bergerie c'est une vieille maison qu'à
plus de 200 ans à ces 1786 avec louis
saez qui a voulu au départ faire une
ferme expérimentale qui très vite et de
est devenue une bergerie avec l'arrivée
des mérinos d'espagne et à partir de là
ça a été la première école de berger il
ya eu plusieurs autres écoles qui se
sont monté une école sur l'insémination
artificielle ou sur l'élevage des poules
pondeuses ou de ce qu'on appelle de
l'aviculture et depuis une quinzaine
d'années le nouveau projet
d'établissement est un projet autour de
l'agroécologie donc finalement on a
toujours été des précurseurs des
nouvelles orientations agricoles donc
effectivement on entendu parler du
développement durable mais nous ça fait
une quinzaine d'années qu'on y travaille
d'accord m'a écouté merci beaucoup pour
toutes ces informations vous qu'on
rappelle que la bergerie vous accueille
pour des animations cirque à la ferme
jusqu'au 2 mars et c'est tous les après
midi à partir de 14 heures merci
frédéric mercier alors on continue je
vais vous donner quelques autres idée de
sortie en famille et notamment pour les
âmes les enfants en cette période donc
de vacances alors tout d'abord c'est un
estaminet à magny les hameaux qui
propose donc aux enfants jusqu'au 21
février donc encore trois jours de
confectionner des costumes de
super-héros attention pensez à réserver
le musée de la ville quant à lui propose
différents ateliers de sensibilisation à
l'espace urbain et à l'art urbain
notamment gras sur deux sculptures des
maquettes des espaces verts entre autres
et ce sont les après midi des mercredis
jeudis et samedis de toutes les vacances
enfin attrape la mairie accueille les
enfants et les parents pour des
répétitions du carnaval de printemps
donc ce carnaval aura lieu le 22 mars
prochain donc il faut donc le préparer
au programme danses et chants avec les
artistes de la compagnie difé kako et
pour information 3 autres répétitions
hormis la le 21 février seront prévues
en mars les 9 18 et 22 mars et enfin
dernière idée pour vos enfants vous
pouvez leur proposer de découvrir des
senteurs et de composer leur parfum ce
sera exclusivement la journée du 26
février
l'atelier les petits guerlain et c'est à
la cour des senteurs à versailles enfin
voilà une autre idée de sortie
éventuellement en famille dans le cadre
de la 3ème saison pulsations urbaine
consacré cette année aux 30 ans du hip
hop sur le territoire le musée de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines donc
présente une nouvelle exposition dédiée
aux cultures urbaines qui donne la
parole aux street artist images de
claire cambier
blanc gore
1984 il ya trente ans déjà la mythique
compagnie de danse hip hop black blanc
beur faisait leurs premiers pas à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines territoire qui
fut l'un des berceaux du genre en france
célèbre tout au long de l'année cet
anniversaire au travers de différents
rendez vous parmi ceux à ne pas manquer
notons que le musée de la ville présente
jusqu'au 28 juin pour une nouvelle
exposition baptisée street culture sky
elle s'intéresse naturellement au hip
hop les plus largement aux cultures
urbaines sket dance est grave notamment
cette culture là est une culture
importante sur le territoire pas
seulement à saint quentin en yvelines
mais c'est une culture qui est souvent
pas assez reconnus et elle mérite qu'on
en parle mais c'est aussi une culture
qui a des valeurs vraiment propres qui
sont importantes et revendiquée à la
fois de se débrouiller soi même mais
aussi du respect de l'autre
2 la valeur par la compétence et pas par
par ce combat ou par la valeur sociale
c'est des choses qui sont très
importantes pour les hip hopeurs c'est
qu'on a voulu traduire dans cette
exposition une rétrospective à travers
laquelle le musée donne la parole aux
street artistes du territoire qui ont
accepté de témoigner de leur univers de
création chacun apporte qu'est ce qu'une
idée en fait on moi j'ai travaillé ce
truc dans le groupe du skate
ou on a partagé nos vidéos beaucoup
plient chez
les lieux où on aime bien se retrouver
qu'on appelle des spots et après en
fonction des autres contacts lui ont
apporté
prévu qu'un appareil soit leurs spots
sur leur façon pour objet textes vidéos
et objets d'époque ou tu la visite une
occasion de s'interroger sur l'évolution
de ces cultures je pense que vous avez
un petit peu plus accessible pour tous
il ya beaucoup qui en vivent maintenant
je pense que ça viendra fait de la danse
ou autre mais de pouvoir le toucher à ce
monde-là cette semaine c'était un petit
peu à l'époque un peu de ghettos
petit peu un aspect un peu négatif je
pense que maman ça a complètement changé
ça c'est beaucoup plus ouvert
battle listant les mauvais le skate on
le voit partout et un come back du skate
le graphe les mecs ce dernier maintenant
des artistes très connus donc cerexhe
france a largement évolué les codes
vestimentaires ont évolué aussi sur les
skateurs ont les danseurs complètement
changé pour s'initier à ces pratiques
trois ateliers pochoir graf et glisse
animés par des professionnels seront
présentés de mars à avril
retrouvons sans plus attendre nicolas
gervais pour sa chronique en un casque
à la tête de l' orchestre manifesto en
résidence à la merise attrape mélanie
l'élite chez hbo cherche à initier un
nouveau public à la musique classique 1
nicolas gérerait la rencontre et
avec la paix mais ce qu elles oeuvrent
pour la promotion de la musique
classique notamment avec les scolaires
et elle dirige l'orchestré manifesto qui
sera en concert le 15 mars à la merise
attrape voici mais l'a dit levy thiébaut
dans le kiosque locales disent oui on
est bilingue dans le casque hi hi
c'est alors qu'est ce que j'ai créée en
2005 parce que je faisais une carrière
de chef invité donc quand vous êtes
invités on vous dit tall date et l'heure
tels programmes tels soliste et
finalement vous choisissez rien
l'intérêt de manifesto c'est que je
choisissais mes propres programmes je
choisis c'est la manière de les faire
aussi par exemple cette manière que j'ai
de présenter les concerts de donner les
clefs de l'ecoute au public et manifesto
permettait tout ça ce sont des musiciens
qui sont issus la plupart pratiquement
tous du cnsm de paris mais en réalité on
a l'impression c'est un orchestre à ces
jeunes quand on dit ça mais en fait ils
ont commencé en 2005 et qui sont restés
finalement tant qu' ils se sont mariés
ils ont fait des enfants et puis
finalement ils sont si jeune que ça mais
c'est ce qui fait la force de leur
caisse et que je suis arrivé à les
fidéliser
m
c'est l'association pour la promotion de
la musique classique sur saint quentin
en yvelines et sur tout le territoire
des yvelines et le lien c'est ma
rencontre en fait entre hervé farge et
mois à la suite d'un concert il m'a dit
voilà
je voudrais renouveler l'équipe aussi
puisque pierre michel durand avec
promethean effet je crois dix ans avec
la pms q donc au bout d'un moment c'est
vrai qu'il faut renouveler les idées
renouveler le répertoire renouvelé
l'énergie tout simplement les gens et
j'ai rencontré hervé fages à ce moment
là donc l'idée c'était de mettre en
place des concerts pédagogiques des
concerts symphoniques de l'opéra pour
que les enfants écoutent de l'opéra
méchante aussi dans l'opéra on travaille
aussi avec le choeur d'adultes
voilà donc d'être très très variés
d'aller dans les classes pour faire
travailler les enfants d'être très
variés d'être multiples sur le
territoire
l'année dernière on est allé faire le
concert symphonique chez l'autre de 6 à
la mairie ve est bon comme on s'apprécie
qu'il apprécie beaucoup le travail de la
pms cul et l'esprit de hervé fage on a
décidé que ce concert symphonique que
seraient régulièrement à la merise ça
permet d'accueillir plus de monde et on
fait le concert pédagogique de la veille
aussi à la merise
quand je suis arrivé à la pms q j'ai
découvert parce que je ne savais pas
encore et c'était de ma faute qu'il y
avait la branche symphonique avec leurs
caisses qui est vrai pour les enfants il
y avait une branche extrêmement
importante une deuxième branche
artistique et la musique de chambre et ô
combien importante puisqu'elle est
représentée par des solistes
internationaux importants dirigé dans la
direction artistique est faite par
marianne piketty quéveau le violoniste
et j'ai dit oui je comprends pas comment
ça se fait que ces deux branches ne se
rejoignent jamais et ça a été finalement
l'idée marianne a été très joyeuse de ça
et moi aussi on s'entend très bien et
l'idée de du tir bas les solistes de la
villedieu qui la branche musique de
chant de la pms cul et leurs caisses
manifesto qui est la branche symphonique
de la paix msq se retrouvent pour un
concert ce sont des solistes prestigieux
beaucoup de solistes français actuel qui
marche très très bien en france qui
viennent aux suns la vie de dieu il ya
exavier philippe ce marianne piketty
ophélie gaillard emmanuel bertrand
pascal amoyel
non non
j'y vais pas
on s'est entendus très vite avec
marianne sur la musique populaire parce
que la musique populaire ça a l'air très
simple comme ça mais de par sa
simplicité parce que c'était des
chansons finalement de rue les
compositeurs s'en sont donné à coeur
joie pour la rendre finalement sa vente
est plus simple plus ils peuvent la
rendre sa vente donc ça a donné des
heures extraordinaire et on s'est dit on
va faire la musique populaire mais à
travers les siècles donc on part de
brahms tchaïkovski avec les variations
rococo dvorjak concerto pour violon de
bras et puis on passe en france avec
deegan de ravel qui est la pièce
maîtresse de musique populaire ce que
c'est de la musique tzigane en fait mais
que ravel a porté à son comble avec une
sophistication d'orchestration
absolument fabuleuse et puis alors après
on rentre vraiment presse dans le xxème
siècle avec du bartok avec du
chostakovitch et puis même avec un
compositeur actuelle qui est maratka
avec le luminar y sommes et on finit
avec un grand final sur les danses
roumaines de bartok qui sont vraiment la
musique populaire sa vente par
excellence
et aussi pour leur castres manifesto est
manifestement maintenant on retrouve
aurélien
nous sommes mercredi c'est donc l'heure
des sorties ciné au micro d' elodie
moine est très bien mais je veux comme
j'aime bien les lego le film j'ai trouvé
bien en plus c'est une bonne histoire il
était mortel le film j'ai bien aimé et
j'aimais bien aussi quand il y avait
des dragons et 10 rebonds pour les
enfants je pense que c'est très bien bon
après pour les parents c'est un petit
peu long mais bon le principal c'est de
les voir heureux en sortant donc très
bien qu'ils étaient super me miel chabot
film pour enfants et création légaux
elles sont super eh ben c'est pas mal
mais peut-être que on pourrait dire
qu'il ya certaines astuces que les
enfants pourraient pas bien comprendre
comme la relation entre les lego et la
relation entre le père et le fils
j'attendais pas un chef-d'oeuvre mais je
trouve que c'est classique ce correspond
à ce que à ce qu'on attendait oui c'est
bien joué c'est bien
ça constitue bien les faits réels
c'était plutôt très bien un bon péplum
plutôt sympathique je m'attendais pas à
ce que
ce sera un aussi beau film français plus
que c'était série b un peu mais
franchement elle devient
alors comme vous le savez la chronique
siné fixe est aussi l'occasion de donner
la parole un professionnel du cinéma et
cette semaine c'est au tour de del pino
responsable du grenier à sel à trappes
cette semaine je vous parlais de mon
coup de coeur c'est une minuscule le fil
minuscule film d'animation français qui
a été tourné dans des décors naturels et
sur l'innocence est d'accord on a
rajouté les des petits insectes en
animations c'est un film qui à la base
était des séries qui passait à la télé
et là ils ont fait un long métrage qui
dure une heure et demie nous on
conseille à partir de 5 ans l'histoire
c'est
des fourmis noires qui ont trouvé une
boîte de sucre abandonné lors d'un pique
nique et cette boîte de sucre est aussi
convoité par des fourmis rouges et donc
les petites bagarres qui va se
déclencher ont conçu cette histoire à
travers les yeux d'une jeune coccinelles
et c
et on la voit grandir pendant le film
c'est très grosse et très mini rond il
ya de très belles images et s'est mué
pense pas à mon mieux et on verra où on
allait les bruitages
la libreta des animaux un vrai beau film
très intéressant et là surtout pour les
vacances profitez-en je vous conseille
vraiment vraiment on le garde donc deux
semaines et
venez en profiter mais ne regarder
qui aurait pu croire que tout allait
dépendre du courage une petite
coccinelle
minuscule
nos traditions notre émission est à
présent donc terminé merci de nous avoir
suivis je vous retrouve donc la semaine
prochaine en direct à 18h30 d'ici là bas
profitez donc de toutes les idées
sorties que nous avons donnée à mercredi